this overall is online the wearer is a
walking Wi-Fi hotspot it might sound
like science fiction but it's high-tech
fashion by Bora occurs Dyke the young
dutch designer got the idea for what
he's dubbed the bee bee suit at a music
festival one thing we needed everywhere
is Wi-Fi you need internet it's like
okay let's put Wi-Fi inside everybody
was talking about wearable tech and I
didn't really see wearable technology
and I thought like puppies if I talk
about it I really want to wear he said
like okay now I wanted to make a suit
because I'm yeah I'm an partly a fashion
designer I felt like yeah this big
jumpsuit people who recognize and then
they will ask like why do you have this
suit and then you can explain going to
the Wi-Fi then we have the BB suit [ __ ]
onto the BB suit now the outfit itself
is an internet provider anyone standing
nearby has Wi-Fi reception and the
wearer can be located via GPS it's a
bold idea but that's what occurs Dyke is
known for back in 2011 he made waves at
Paris Fashion Week with his first
collection some of the pieces date to
2009 and were part of his final project
at the renowned Design Academy Eindhoven
occurs Dyke launched his own label in
2010 he's been able to finance his own
designs by collaborating with some big
name labels like Nike and Louis Vuitton
no doubt the young dutch designer is a
visionary he supplies the ideas and the
aesthetics then he turns to the techies
to get help implementing them we have
two different components here on one
side we have the Wi-Fi here it is
actually the source that make a Wi-Fi
network appear for the people around
this route we have a battery that make
sure the power is fed through to the
Wi-Fi and then we have the fabric itself
which has the copper yarn so we use a
cover like this and it's really nice
because that's it has a coating so to
make sure that there's no short circuits
in the fabric combining technology and
textiles that's what occurs Dyke strives
for in his work in this video that he
produced himself he explains his passion
for futuristic apparel
and the young dutch designer isn't the
only one many other designers are
pursuing a fascination with high-tech
called intelligent fashion it's been
drawing increased attention the past few
years well known labels like
berlin-based moon have been
experimenting with integrating LED
lights into fabric and British designer
hussein chalayan created skirts and
dresses whose length can be altered with
electronic commands research has played
a major role in the development of
high-tech designs the electronic
components have grown smaller and the
clothes more flexible I think the really
the challenging part is standing next to
the machine and small things like the
copper thread needs to go into the
machine but it twists and the moment it
twisted breaks okay how can we solve
this and then now the suit is finished
but can we wash it no so the suit isn't
quite ready for daily wear not a problem
for a curse dyke for him fashion design
is about playing with ideas not that we
want everybody to walk in this suit
that's definitely not the ID our goal
for the future it's like to create a new
platform and to see where usability and
user interface can go the moment you go
away from the screen and on and around
the body with his high-tech overalls
Bora occurs Dyke has taken the first
steps toward making that vision a
reality